hey guys it's Alanna and welcome to my
channel today I am drinking some cider
at a Magic the Gathering Duels of the
Planeswalkers 2015 preview event so the
game is set to come out next month so
I'm gonna check it out it's it a cool
little bar in Sydney so I flew down for
this one and have a lot of fun so fun
so I just thought hands-on with the game
and marsley was really really impressed
with the odd style the music was also
really really great the new building
feature which is new to this one was
freaking awesome
my biggest advice as well for people who
want to get into magic a few of you have
been like hey please make out how to
play video is to play shows of the
plants woman so is one lost you that you
can still get on Steam and on Xbox Live
and stuff and um yeah I sort of teach
you how to play better than anything
else so I would definitely recommend
checking them out
that was also an archery competition
with these to shoot one of the giant
cardboard cutouts and I didn't wean but
if you get like 20 points I think then
you can win this like giant collection
of goodies here so we got um like a new
intro deck back at the hotel just to get
us all started then there's another
intro pack here I've got a red one and
red a blue one
I got paradise another deck and a USB
that apparently has like a whole bunch
of the photos and trailer and stuff on
it
so that's pretty much it got to check
out the games coming out in July and I
guess I'll see you guys next time I'm
gonna go check out Vivid Sydney which is
this cool light show that's on I'm
sitting tonight so I'll see you all next
time bye